the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
i know i'm not the only one who has been
wondering what george rr martin thinks
of the new house of the dragon teaser
trailer that was recently released by
hbo as you all know the song of ice and
fire universe is his creation after all
well on his not a blog website he did
just that only a few days ago george rr
martin let us know what he thinks about
house of the dragon let me show you what
he said
now the first thing he says is the
dragons are coming yes i know most of
you have already seen this what can i
say i am busy juggling so many balls so
many projects posting stuff on my not a
blog website is not my highest priority
so things may always be a little bit
behind here for the handful of you who
have been off the internet for the last
few days however hbo has released the
first official teaser trailer for house
of the dragon here it is
then at the bottom of his blog he says
enjoy and yes i love it too ryan and
miguel and their team are kicking ass
and taking names
now for those of you who don't know the
ryan and miguel he is referring to are
ryan condell and miguel sapochnick the
showrunners for house of the dragon i
think this is really good news now that
we know george rr martin loves it as
well now i don't know how many of you
saw one of my more recent videos but i
think this show is in really good hands
with ryan condell as one of house of the
dragon's co-creators he actually said
some things during his interview with
george rr martin that made me think he
just might be the best man for the job
now if you saw that recent video you
don't need to watch any further but if
you missed it i would highly recommend
watching until the very end i want to
show you why i think ryan will be a much
better showrunner and writer than david
and dan the old writers for game of
thrones
i'm sure some of you have been wondering
if ryan condell is the right fit for
house of the dragon some of you might be
wondering if he even knows anything
about a song of ice and fire well that
answer is yes it seems like he knows a
lot more than the game of thrones
writers did david and dan were fans of a
song of ice and fire whereas it sounds
like ryan is a student of a song of ice
and fire there is a very big difference
i think ryan also has one big advantage
over david and dan house of the dragon
already has an ending george rr martin
laid out all the groundwork for house of
the dragons ending many years ago now i
really want you to hear what else ryan
said during the interview because i
think it says a lot about who he is as a
writer
you know we had done an uh
a round of development
if you go back
when it was clear that the game of
thrones was ending that dave and dan
wanted to end it after seven seasons or
something
hbo started looking to develop other
other shows
and um
the two that i pitched were dancing to
dragon which became
uh house of dragon and uh
the duncan egg thing
but there were a number of other shows
that were developed at that time
most of them put together by writers
that hbo hired
uh
who had never read my books
and who i guess had watched the show and
they were doing and when we were getting
into this i didn't want that anymore i
obviously none of those shows ultimately
got on the air i thought you know i want
people if they're going to be working in
my world i want them to actually have
read my books and i liked ryan's work
and i knew they knew the world he had
read the books so
once again in that bar at the four
seasons uh yeah where it all uh started
there
how tell me about how you guys met a
little bit because i think our audience
would actually really enjoy this i'm a
super fan and i i found the books
at this point over 20 years ago
and uh i love them i was a huge uh uh
tolkien fan lord of the rings just that
you know worshiped at the at the at the
altar of it uh the movies were coming
out and i had i just reread them and i
was in this kind of fantasy mode and i
was like what else is out there and a
friend had recommended hey if you love
tolkien you should really check this out
because it's it's really the only it's
the it's the it's the only thing since
tolkien that really got me up out of my
seat fantasy-wise i've liked other
fantasies i've enjoyed things uh there's
some great classic books out there but
nothing to me held a candle to to
tolkien but this did and it was of
course the first book game of thrones
and i read it and i just i fell all the
way in i was all in like you know i i
couldn't believe how good it was i i
read all three there were three books at
the time storm swords that just had just
been published and i just devoured them
and then went back and devoured them
again and i and it just it became my
favorite thing so and and this happened
at a time where i was learning to to
write myself uh i was very interested in
screenwriting i had written a couple of
scripts i was starting to try to make a
a career of this i was in my early 20s
and
you know cut to a number of years later
i've now broken in i still love these
books i'm a huge fan of the television
show i'm watching it all i tried to get
at some point i tried to get my agents
to get me a staff writer job on the show
and they were like they don't have staff
writers it's just the two of them write
the whole show
so um i respected him so much and
actually learned so much from him as a
writer because i i mean i credit even
though the
the books are prose books george started
as a dramatic writer a screenwriter and
televisions the books are written in
this
dave you've read them they're written in
this incredibly cinematic way with hooks
at the end of chapters there's dialogue
i mean it's written you could very
easily just put slug lines into those
books and create scenes out of them it's
not a novelistic style of writing so i
learned a lot about character and
storytelling and atmosphere and theme
and all these you know
literary tools like you know
foreshadowing and how to you know how to
write prophecy compelling prophecy that
doesn't seem you know uh
uh dinky or foregone conclusion all
these things that i i still use today
that i learned from those books so it
was just really exciting for me to be
able to meet george and then we and then
we hit it off and then you know on down
the road we go you know some you know
five six seven years later it turned
into a job offer which still i mean as
still it still
blows my mind that i'm that i'm sitting
here doing this show
now maybe it's only me but it really
does sound like ryan will be focusing on
the things that many fans saw as david
and dan's weaknesses i mean they
basically admitted to leaving certain
aspects out of the show i'm sure some of
you remember the interview where david
benioff said themes are for 8th grade
book reports this angered a lot of fans
and for good reason i'm sure some of you
also remember what david and dan said
after game of thrones ended they said
they didn't want to focus on any of the
fantasy elements as much because they
wanted a wider fanbase i don't see these
as their only weaknesses either i know
i'm not the only one who is angry with
the way david and dan handled the
fantasy elements the magic and even the
prophecies in the show this greatly
affected the faceless men the lord of
light the night king azor ahai the
valonqar the dragon has three heads and
so many other amazing aspects of a song
of ice and fire after season four of
game of thrones when david and dan were
no longer following the books they
basically abandon all of that so what
does that mean for house of the dragon
well if you listen to what ryan condell
said during his interview with george rr
martin not only does it sound like he is
interested in those things but it also
sounds like they will be a focus of his
as well
i don't think ryan will leave any of
those aspects out of house of the dragon
this is why i think he is a better
writer than david and dan and this is
why i think he is a student of a song of
ice and fire whereas david and dan were
only fans it doesn't matter how amazing
your show looks and sounds if the
writing sucks game of thrones season 8
was incredible in every single way
except for the writing and that's why
many fans see that final season as a
failure
i believe this is our most significant
update regarding house of the dragon
because i think this will have a greater
effect on the show over any other area
we have seen so far we unfortunately had
to learn that the hard way with game of
thrones i honestly do not see that
happening with house of the dragon after
hearing this interview i feel like the
show is now in good hands and let us not
forget ryan condole isn't the only
showrunner miguel sapochnick is there as
well who we all know as the director
from some of game of thrones greatest
episodes like hard home battle of the
bastards and the winds of winter i don't
know about all of you but i feel a lot
better knowing george rr martin was a
writer for the first episode and knowing
someone like ryan is there to manage all
of the other episodes after that i just
hope he doesn't let us down
now if you're someone who is waiting for
my next episode of game of thrones
season 9 i will be releasing that video
next there was so much new house of the
dragon information i had to get out some
of these videos first now i want to
finish my version of season 9 so i can
start working on a lot of other things i
hope i will see all of you back here for
that video as always thank you all so
much for watching this one have a great
day everyone i will see you soon
bye
[Music]
you